herborn die ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland-pfalz v3 er hat gesagt die
leute sind kaputt sie können nicht mehr
aber sie entscheiden jetzt ein endlos
ewig lockdown völlig ohne perspektive
was glauben sie wielange deutschland das
aushalten kann
ein endlos lockern wollen wir nicht und
ich teile auch die einschätzung dass wir
alle in der bevölkerung ist natürlich
maximal belastet sind durch die lange
zeit die wir jetzt schon beschränkungen
haben
aber wir können nicht einfach aus dieser
naturkatastrophe corona aussteigen wenn
wir bei zu holen infektionszahlen
lockern
dann das haben wir in vielen ländern
gesehen dann kommt sofort zur
gegenbewegung zum jojo-effekt man
steigen die infektionszahlen wieder und
dann sind noch härtere beschränkungen
notwendig und genau den wollen wir uns
ersparen sollen wir wollen stabil öffnen
aber die menschen hier brauchen die
glauben ihnen das nicht mehr dass das in
ein paar wochen weitergehen
wir haben gestern gesprochen mit
menschen die würde ich den tränen nahe
sind was ich sagen unsere läden gehen
kaputt wir kriegen noch nicht mal
wirtschaftshilfe gleichzeitig hören wir
auch aus ihrer fraktion zum beispiel
ghana schimke die in der fraktion gesagt
hat die menschen im osten erleben wende
20 erlebnisse müssen sie nicht endlich
den menschen mehr hoffnung machen also
wir müssen den menschen immer die
berechtigte hoffnung machen und die
berechtigte hoffnung ist dass wir im
sommer jede mine impfangebot machen
können dass die pandemie dann ihren
schrecken verliert das wenn wir
konsequent bleiben und wir haben ja
momentan eine gute zahlen entwicklung
das wird an weitere öffnung schritte
machen können aber wir müssen auch die
unsicherheiten benennen die wir haben
und der steigende anteil von
virusvarianten die ansteckender sind
sind eine unbekannte und deshalb kann
ich nicht jetzt einen plan machen und
sagen was in den nächsten zehn wochen
wann passiert weil wir alle damit
rechnen dass im laufe des märz jetzt
auch die virus mutationen in deutschland
immer mehr relevant werden von seinen
positionen die zahlen wieder hochgehen
wenn das dem entspricht dann können sie
doch nicht ernsthaft glauben dass wir
die 35 kommen nein wir müssen da die
infektion immer so steuern dass sie
nicht wieder hoch gehen dass das ziel
was wir haben ist dass wir die
infektionszahlen unter 35 dadurch dass
wir nicht durch beschränkungen dann
noch das infektionsgeschehen
kontrollieren sondern durch die
gesundheitsämter das quasi wenn jedes
gesundheitsamt wenn jeder an jedem tag
nur zehn oder zwanzig fälle zu
bearbeiten hat dann können die die
kontakte tages genau nachvollziehen
können alle in quarantäne schicken die
ansteckung verdächtig sind und dann
kontrollieren wir das
infektionsgeschehen dann brauchen wir
dieses extreme maß und kontakt
reduzierung nicht mehr aber da müssen
wir hinkommen
herr brown wie weltbild kritisieren dass
impfstoff debatte sehr hart in den
letzten wochen werden gibt getötet zu
dem was gestern passiert ist der gipfel
der gescheiterten sie verlängern den
lock down
es gibt keinen impfstoff kam hoffnung
werden andere urlaub machen dürfen und
im sommerurlaub machen können weil sie
besser geimpft sind ist in wahrheit die
tatsache dass wir nicht genügend
impfstoff haben in deutschland der grund
dass sie weiter in diesem dauer dauer
dauerlauf dunkeln nein also wenn man mal
sieht israel als das land was sozusagen
am besten mit impfstoff versorgt ist wo
wir immer mit ein bisschen neid auch
hinschauen ist auch gerade in einem log
dateien mit auch im anfang mehr einmal
alles auf rädern auf bahn hat eine
riesige welle erlebt und ob sozusagen
die nächsten öffnung schritte gut sind
muss man gehen muss man dann ja immer
mal sehen für uns war beim impfstoff
immer klar wir müssen die produktion
auch steigern
warum haben sie damals als
kanzleramtsminister nicht darauf
gedrängt zusammen mit ihren sparen bei
der eu zu sagen moment mal leute wir
müssen viel viel mehr kaufen und am ende
wenn wir zu viel impfstoff haben können
wir das an entwicklungsländer geben und
weiter geht
wir haben mit den unternehmen gesprochen
und haben gesagt wie viel könnt ihr
produzieren und können wir euch helfen
bei der produktionssteigerung wir werden
die produktionskapazitäten auch in
deutschland und in europa weit über
unseren bedarf hochfahren und wir werden
ab april sehen dass dann unsere
impfzentren auch voll sind aber die
vorstellung dass die leute sind freiheit
war die 101 jährige gestern gesprochen
die gesagt hat sie sie kommt nicht durch
in der import leyen sieht bekommen kann
angebot die die menschen sind
verzweifelt weil sie einfach sagen wie
kann das sein dass ein land wie
deutschland nicht genügend impfstoff
geordert hatte und schauen nach
großbritannien in die usa wo einfach
mehr geld ausgegeben wurde das hat nicht
nur mit zulassungen zu tun sondern
einfach
stärker investiert wurde also ich will
es einfach noch mal sehr deutlich sagen
es war von anfang an immer klar
deshalb haben wir die ständige
impfkommission die leopoldina und auch
den ethikrat gebeten die priorisierung
zu machen dass man in den ersten drei
vier monaten nicht genügend impfstoff
haben wird und deshalb priorisieren muss
und deshalb ist ganz klar die 101
jährige ist jetzt dran für dieses
impfstoff da und das ist sozusagen jetzt
eine frage der umsetzung dass sie ihren
impftermin bekommt aber impfstoff ist
für die da wir werden im april erleben
dass unsere impfzentren unter voller
hoch last laufen weil wir jetzt auch
erste modellierung gemacht haben wir uns
zeigen
dieses erste quartal ist wirklich vom
knappheit geplant geprägt aber im
zweiten quartal werden wir sehr große
teile dieser priorisierung abarbeiten
können und im dritten quartal also noch
im sommer wollen wir jedem bürger in
deutschland ein impfangebot machen und
ich glaube weil wir ein gutes und
ausgebautes gesundheitssystem haben dass
wir dann auch im internationalen
vergleich uns nicht scheuen müssen weil
dann wenn viel impfstoff verfügbar sind
wir besser als andere sender auch in der
lage ihn auch wirklich zu verhindern
deshalb wenn sie darüber nachdenken wann
sie hier wieder vom kanzleramt
biergarten sitzen dürfen nach ostern
pfingsten sommer frühherbst was im
sommer ganz sicher was ist sommer für
sie dann der einundzwanzigste juni oder
erst ende september
ja es gibt doch gerade gesagt dass wir
den blick auf die mutation und vieles
andere keine versprechungen machen
sollten die wir nicht halten können und
deshalb eine aussage auf dem datum
genauer basieren
ich hab gesagt diese pandemie wird im
laufe dieses jahres ihren schrecken
verlieren und deshalb können wir im
sommer auch irgendwann wieder im
biergarten sitzt herzlichen dank herr
braun für das gespräch und alles gute
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren